a real deterrent would be if we had a
system that worked in the end what this
really is all about is the pictures of
people crossing by boats but also the
awareness there's 177 000 people at the
last count in temporary accommodations
in which are hotels around the country
that's because the government's not
managing the situation now I don't know
the situation or the details of uh what
happened to the many more refugees that
there are in Germany than there are in
the UK and if there's a lower Grant rate
maybe it's because they actually are
process their refugees whereas we don't
process ours those that we do process by
the way turn out 80 to be actual
refugees however there is not a single
safe route there is no resettlement
program there is nothing equivalent to
Ukraine Afghanistan Syria or Hong Kong
which by the way are the only places you
can legally come from now as a result of
this bill so what are we saying to those
people we're saying we will not help you